it's difficult really to overstate just
how angry how furious people are across
France at these pension reforms in
essence the government wants to push up
the retirement age as you were saying
from 62 to 64 and this country is
convulsing it's seething at the prospect
of that to make it clear this isn't
something really just to do with
President macron it's been a rail of
French politics dating back to 1995 but
president macron has made a decentral
platform of his second term uh in office
and it looks like he's going to push it
through his special Constitutional
Powers bypassing a democratic vote in
the lower house and it looks as though
it's going to go through the no
confidence vote table for Monday will
probably fail the bigger question is
what happens now on the streets we're in
place de la Concorde we saw what
happened yesterday significant riots
yesterday thousands of people people
throwing cobblestones at police uh look
down there you can make out the flashing
blue lights in the distance a signif
African police presence here at the
moment this demonstration is starting
around now there's a few hundred people
it's quite subdued at the moment but we
are expecting more people there's
another demonstration planned uh for
tomorrow night at the same time and
there are similar things going on around
the country the question is where will
all of this lead will the protests will
the demonstrations will the riots become
more frequent and more violent and
ultimately will it bring paralysis to
the rest of the country I think that's
the question that President mackerel is
having to wrestle with tonight